No doubt you've seen
the chaos in the streets.
We must make an example
or France will fall.
What would you do if this assignment
of defense was transferred to you?
I promise you brilliant successes.
What is this costume you have on?
This is my uniform.
I led the French victory at Toulon.
What is your name?
Napoleon.
Has the course of my life just changed...
Napoleon?
I am destined for greatness.
But those in power only see me as a sword.
I suggest you take the throne as king.
Shall we vote?
Long live the emperor!
This vermin has held the world hostage...
with his egotism and his lack
of simple good manners.
You think you're great.
You're just a tiny little brute
that is nothing without me.
All of Europe is uniting forces against me.
What's the outcome of this
if you don't succeed?
Your majesty, we are discovered.
Good.
Ice!
It's a trap!
I'm the first to admit
when I make a mistake...
I simply never do.